hey folks i'm lucy and joining me is our
cyberpunk 2077 reviewer cali plaguey
hello
and jake decker who has also been
playing a bunch of cyberpunk
oh yeah almost 45 hours now
that's a lot but before we get into what
the two of them thought of the game
just a quick note up front about why
this isn't our traditional review format
featuring bespoke video footage that
we've captured ourselves
that is because there are two different
embargoes for cyberpunk and today's
is the written embargo that means that
cali can post her written review
featuring images that she has captured
in game
but not with video that we have captured
ourselves
that is under a separate embargo so that
means
like this video subscribe to gamespot to
make sure you can watch the video review
when it's ready or head over to
gamespot.com now if you want to read
cali's full review so just wanted to get
that no
uh we have our official video review
coming with our own footage
as soon as we are able to so
housekeeping is out of the way
let's get into it the two of you how
much have you played
uh and which life path did you both pick
cali i'll come to you first
um i've played 50 hours so far
i am at the very end but i keep hitting
a freezing bug which we'll get to
so i haven't finished it but i've i've
faced look i've almost finished it
um and i've done a bunch of side stuff i
picked the nomad life path
um because i thought it would make more
sense on like the if
you know this is the first time i'm
playing the game i don't know the city
that's like the background of a nomad so
i decided to go with
um yeah you are an outsider yourself
just as
v is in the game so that makes total
sense to me
right that was the idea jake what about
you yeah so i
picked nomad for my first playthrough i
think it took me about 40 hours or so
and today i just started one as a corpo
so i've seen
those two life paths as of now but i
have finished the game
i have seen multiple endings at this
point just by save scumming essentially
right and and so i guess that means
there is a specific moment in the game
where it's like this is the point of
number 10.
yeah i think that's worth pointing out
is that you will get to a point where it
will say
hey finish up all the side quests you
want to do because you're about to get
to the final section of the game
gotcha which is kind of reassuring
because from the sounds of it it does
have a bunch
of endings and i mean a quick question
before we get into like
the deeper kind of nitty-gritty of it is
like are these endings do they
vary much
i i wanna i don't wanna say a whole lot
on this
but it seems like yes they do seem to
vary a lot and it seems like your
choices on endings will depend on which
characters you help out through the game
kind of similar to the witcher in some
sense
but if i remember correctly the witcher
had about three major endings and this
seems to have
significantly more than that but right
now it's really hard to say because like
i said
i've only done one playthrough
so yes all right well you mentioned
characters there so that seems
a good segue as any uh to talk about the
characters that we'll
encounter in night city but we'll start
by talking
about the one who has been in our hearts
i guess and at the forefront of most of
the marketing it's going to be keanu
rubes
playing johnny silverhand now callie
when you were playing what did you think
of kiana's portrayal
how is he as a character and interacting
with you
as v it's from my point of view i just
hope that it's not just
another celebrity in a game you know
he's like really taking on this role and
giving it his all
oh i would say it's definitely more than
just another celebrity in a game like i
the thing about johnny silverhand is
that he's a huge [ __ ] he's
such a douche and that's part of his
character
and it makes sense um and it's you know
it's a testament to
keanu's performance that i actually
liked johnny silverhand despite all the
[ __ ] he says
because i should say this is going to be
probably an
m rated review because there's a lot of
uh
swearing in the game and a lot of a lot
of heavy topics so
i'm just gonna go for it but um
yeah he he makes johnny silverhand like
a
nuanced likable character i mean i think
the writing does that as well but i
think
i i don't know that i would have liked
him as much if he had been played by
somebody else
um i thought i thought he was really
well done
uh i thought like his um like delivery
of the the dialogue was really strong um
and yet he's a fascinating character
johnny silverhand is
is uh complex
he's a lot he's just a lot um
and yeah there's a there's a quest that
like
really opens up who he is and opens up
like uh
more to hit more sides to him that i
really really liked and
it helped deepen my appreciation for the
character a lot um i texted jake this
after seeing one sequence that involved
a lot of drinking and i was like i
am shocked johnny silverhand didn't die
choking on his own vomit because
wow like that's the vibe like if
there's one thing i could say about him
to like get across what kind of person
he is
that's probably what i would say like
for the
the basic stuff that i was gonna say
that really uh
explains him in a very very specific way
that i can imagine what kind of
character he is um
jake what about how you as a character
interact with johnny's helper hand
because
it's not just like well he's in your
head yeah
this was actually probably one of my
favorite aspects of the game is just
how involved he is in all these quests
like
like i think cali brought up a really
good point about how
keanu reeves really sells this character
like the writing is good
but i do not think i would like johnny
silverhand nearly as much if it didn't
have the charm of keanu reeves and i
think that's very intentional
i imagine cd projekt red knew that like
they needed someone with a lot of charm
otherwise
he might be a very hard character to
like but he
appears in almost all of the side quests
the main quests you do in some form or
another
sometimes he'll just be there to make
fun of you because you'll make a dumb
decision sometimes he'll be there
to egg you on to push things further
than you probably should while other
times you'll just be like hey v
you should get the [ __ ] out of here you
don't want anything to do with this
and you just kind of have the option to
ignore him and i think
for me that's one of the strongest
aspects of his character and the story
is how
he is very much his own character and he
doesn't necessarily like
v right off the bat so there's like this
sort of
antagonistic feeling you get through
i'd say probably a majority of the game
which i i think works
um for the most part and just having
that as keanu reeves too
kind of helps kind of helps you not hate
him because i think if it wasn't keanu
reeves you might very well
hate him as much as v does at times
but like i don't i don't know you'll be
in a conversation with someone he won't
be interested in he'll just hop on the
bed and like kick his feet up and just
make fun of everything they say and i i
i really enjoyed that
yeah i yeah just to jake's point like i
think
i i really want to reiterate like
there's a lot about johnny that is
not uh likable like he just
doesn't treat women very well or like
historically when he was alive i guess
um but his presence in every scene is so
strong and it really gives
stuff that maybe wouldn't be as
interesting a lot more flavor
um and yeah i think one of my favorite
things is when he gets really invested
in something you're doing and is like
no you should really go see what's over
there you should go see what's going on
um that he yeah he provides a lot of
color
to everything you do and i i would say
he's he's also one of my favorite
uh parts of the game and yeah i agree
really
really strongly with jake too here yeah
there's some moments where he gets so
invested in whatever side quest you're
doing that he'll just be like v this is
the most entertainment i've had for a
long time
you have to follow through and it'll
just be like some dumb quest that
doesn't make any sense but you're like
all right i'm gonna keep going
just for keanu here that's fair but it's
obviously
there are more way more characters in
night city than just
uh keanu's portrayal of johnny like
callie were there any other standouts
like how did you feel the characters
added to the storyline were there ones
that were like just specific standouts
and the rest were kind of meh or was it
a good mix of
writing across all these different
characters um yeah i would say there
were some standouts like i think there's
there's
two characters in particular that i
really really loved the first one
is judy i won't go into her too much but
her quest is like i think
my favorite one that i did um it's like
a you know
there's like characters that have longer
form quests that you go on
um throughout the story and you kind of
have to like wait for them to call you
and have a problem and
she's one of those and i thought it was
really rich
i really enjoyed it it like fit my
personal brand in a way that i can't
explain without spoiling it
like i just loved everything about her
and then the other one
first i love her because of her name her
name is pan am
like the airline yeah like her stories
about friendship
and like finding family and i i really
really loved hers
as far as like the other characters go i
would say like most of the other
characters are pretty
minor like you have people who will call
you from time to time and be like i got
a job for you and they're just
random fixers who like set you up with
gigs
and they're like they're good like
background
color characters but um i would say like
there's there's some uh core characters
that
that really rise to the top jake you and
i did a video a while ago
with phil honcho talking about you know
sex and relationships and cyberpunk and
you know
phil was giving some answers about what
it's like to be interacting with these
characters and you know you're texting
them you talk to them and obviously you
can sleep with them
did those relationships feel meaningful
like and i mean how it i guess is the
portrayal of sexuality in night city
yeah so this is kind of one of the
question marks we still have
uh kelly and i both played as female v
phil who's also been playing played his
mail list so we're kind of waiting to
see
what he finds out uh because based on
our experience it
seems like the characters that you can
have
relationships with are kind of limited
uh that being said maybe there's some
quest lines we missed that show
other characters that you can also uh
have sex with and whatnot but what i
guess stood out to me more
is that a lot of these side characters
spin off into these
well not a lot of these side characters
but some of the best side characters
spin off into these
series of quests kind of like the bloody
baron stuff in the witcher and i think
many people will kind of point to that
being one of the best aspects of the
witcher 3 is how
they really spun out that character
beyond what the main story kind of gave
him
and it seems like a lot of these side
characters kind of follow that path
like as cali was saying pan am has an
entire quest line
uh judy has an entire quest line there's
a couple other characters that
have that as well and it doesn't seem
like relationships are always at the end
of these questlines a lot of them are
just kind of like
hey i've become very good friends with
this person and they might
be able to help me later or you know
maybe i just got some money for them and
got to know their story because
uh there are some characters right that
like you may not get
a big monetary reward for helping out
but like just knowing their story is
satisfying at least
at least in my experience um so so it's
weird because the romance
didn't seem to play as much of a role as
i
expected initially that being said like
phil said
in the thing you can like pay
prostitutes and have sex with them and
there are a bunch of sexual encounters
in the game um but they didn't seem
like the end of the road for a lot of
these relationships which was kind of
refreshing
yeah i had a weird um encounter
with a corporal woman and the
it didn't really like it was just a
short brief thing where like i showed up
in a motel and she was there and she was
like
let's bang but i got it did she
genuinely do like here's my keycard
uh it was a text that was like meet me
here and i showed up maybe 30 hours
after that happened because i was like i
have other stuff to do but i was like
finishing up side quests
and i got a dick sword out of it so
i would say it was worth a while but i
do want to mention
i think the sex scenes are so awkward
because oh really
porn and it's like because it's the
first person
and there's there's one there's one that
i was like this is awkward but like
kind of sweet and i was like
okay with it but there was one that i
was just like squirming in my seat like
i can't wait for this to be over
this is so uncomfortable um i like
reloaded my save and i was like never
mind i want to be friends
um so it it is weird it's all pov
um so you know
it's it's a lot they're kind of like um
montages so you'll see like them being
like
like a dip to black stuff yeah and then
you'll see like their shirts off now and
you know so it's like a you don't have
to it's not the whole
they only lasted a little too long too
oh that's too long
yeah before we move on
from relationships and stuff um i did
want to ask a question because
jake you brought up the bloody baron so
this question for both of you is like
that quest has kind of transcended the
game it came from like when you think of
good writing in video games the quest
that is always brought up
is the bloody baron from the witcher 3.
do you think at any point any quest
in cyberpunk hits those highs
uh yes maybe interesting that's
that's not a good answer uh but i mean
again it's kind of like a shitty
question because i don't want you to
spoil
yeah i i mean i i think the bloody baron
quest line is is hard to match right
because the the redemption arc
there and the different outcomes and the
way you kind of walk away from that with
a bittersweet feeling
is is really powerful and i and like
you're saying like that
that quest line feels transcendent it's
kind of hard to say
at this point but i will say there are
some arcs for me
that that were very close to that and
submissions in particular that were
surprising and interesting and really
added a lot to these characters
um but that was me personally i'm not
sure about how you felt about that cali
um yeah i would say like judy was
absolutely my favorite
there's like a sequence in there that is
just like stunning
honestly like really like i just
i want it i've regretted not saving
right before because i wanted to replay
it
right um but
i i think one of my issues
with cyberpunk 2077 is how
i'm not sure how these individual quests
necessarily fit into the world that's
being created like they're they are
cyberpunk
like for example i met um a guy
who used to be twins who put one
consciousness in the two bodies
and like that was like an interesting
character i didn't follow that quest
because it was like it involved like a
fight and i didn't want to
do brawling so i was just like well
that's sure thing and then i bounced but
like um
there's stuff like that right really
interesting uses of
the setting but
the world is so much there is so much to
parse i find it very hard to parse
and so for me um
like that's what i was looking for from
some of these quests and i didn't
necessarily get
that i did get like characters that i
really really liked and like
interesting just like really
interesting like you know future
stuff to grapple with i'm it's hard to
talk about it without spoiling things
like to
talk around things but um well then
let me let me put this to you then um
because this was one of my concerns
going into the game i mean i haven't
played it yet but like going into
um having the like hear about the
reviews and stuff um
and this is also probably going to be an
avenue to talk about bugs in the game is
that i was concerned
with the sheer amount of content and the
size of it
whether there would be a cohesiveness
throughout
the game yeah that's
that's i would say i don't i don't know
that there is
and that's something that
can get a little weird like
it's interesting because you have this
these like setups like the aesthetic
setup and the background of the pen and
paper game that
you know 2077 draws heavily upon
um i mean like for example there's the
voodoo boys in the
2020 in cyberpunk 2020 the pen and paper
game uh the voodoo boys were like a
group of
white boys who were appropriating like
voodoo to spook people basically
in this game they are
like like haitian like it's a group of
haitian people
who um are in night city because of
i believe climate change induced natural
disaster in haiti
so there's like a haitian diaspora thing
which i think is an interesting backdrop
and there's a dialogue option i got very
early on that you could totally miss
where one of the voodoo boys indicates
to you that
they didn't they don't call themselves
that that's a name that other people
gave them
and i know that was a concern people had
going into this game was like like that
name is a little iffy
um and in changing what the voodoo boys
are from the 2020 game it made it
more iffy for people and so i thought
that was interesting i thought it was
interesting to get a glimpse into like
oh we don't
that's not what we call ourselves um you
like i didn't get anything like that for
the valentinos um it
it's just hard because i there's all of
these like
maybe questionable choices with some of
the aesthetic stuff
some of the the background of of the
gangs
and i didn't always see payoff from that
and it's a story about identity and i
think when you
don't incorporate enough about identity
and about the people in the world you're
creating i think that it just loses its
luster a little bit
yeah i mean in terms of content too and
like
how it's focused it it doesn't have that
um it's hard to describe because i feel
like
the witcher you had you had good reasons
to do all these other quests that
geralt was given like a girl to witcher
so of course he's gonna hunt monsters in
his free time
and like he is basically just following
leads with not a lot of information so
it made sense when someone's like
hey can you help me with this thing and
geralt would be you know begrudgingly
accept
but with this there is a there is a time
factor that you get introduced to
probably about six or seven hours in but
then you're
flooded with all these side quests and
like people asking you of these favors
and all of that stuff is great at least
for the most part
but when you kind of try to bring that
into
the story it's kind of at odds right
because
part of me is like yeah i gotta burn
through this because
there is a strong clock to this plot
that i can't really ignore but at the
same time i know that a lot of the best
stuff
is side content so it's kind of weird
and there is a lot of side content there
is a ton of side content which i
sure will make some people very happy
and worry other folks
because i could see people spending
hours and hours and hours just clearing
out like
gang hideouts uh or just doing a bunch
of quests
uh helping out fixers saving up to buy
cars like there is a lot to do
that doesn't really make sense for your
character to do
if that makes sense a hundred percent
yeah there's so much
i mean there's so much that i ignored
because i was like why
like the the thing i mentioned earlier
where there were twins that were
one person in two bodies that quest was
just like
go brawl some people and i was like i
don't have time for this and then like i
kept getting
texts from people like i have a car for
sale and it was like
i got a free car i know like i'm good i
don't need to buy any more cars
um yeah there's so much in the game that
doesn't feel
necessary and that
like there were definitely quest lines
that i did feel were necessary and like
if somebody asked me like which side
question i do i would have a list
of side quests um but like i think you
should absolutely do this one before you
finish the game like i really loved it
but there's a lot of stuff on the
periphery that i was just like
i am never gonna use this like i don't i
crafted like one thing there's like a
whole crafting interface and like all
this crafting stuff i barely touched it
i barely updated my weapons i went
clothes shopping once
i went clothes shopping all the time
really i probably wasted
so much time trying to find pants that
looked good on v
because i'd find these baggy pants all
the time like i don't want these i know
it's better but i'm just gonna drive
around
every single shop till i find the right
one i was just
i had a really cute outfit from clothes
i looted off of corpses so
different strokes i guess um yeah i was
like a little shirt baggy pants sort of
sort of v um and i got some cute stuff
but um
oh i even got goggles that say [ __ ]
across the front and they've matched my
outfit and i was like i want those
they were perfect i loved them um yeah
the
yeah there's just a lot of like like i
would i would drive by
um there would there's these like you
know like in red dead redemption 2 you
would like
walk by something and it would be like
an emergent thing happening and you
could interact with it there's stuff
kind of like that
but it was just like help the cops catch
these criminals and i was like what if i
don't want to help the cops and then i
would just drive
away and like i didn't do a single one
of them because i just didn't see the
point so
there's a lot like that i wish that the
world felt more essential
um i wish like it
it's god it's so hard to describe
because there's so much
you know but i i did some quests and i
was like i
don't understand what that was trying to
say even like let alone why
i like i was just following it because i
was curious but
i was kind of like oh man i got i have
more important things to do
and to jake's point like there's no
actual clock but it feels like
uh i can't explain it without spoiling
things so like so is it like
limited is it like mass effect 3 where
there was a clock like you knew that you
know
the reapers and all this was happening
at a specific time yet the game kept
giving you these side quests and
realistically you're
in your head you're like i don't have
time for this
but i will go shoot cans off the citadel
with you garrus because
the the time limit is an arbitrary thing
is it kind of more like that
yeah it's definitely like that like you
like kyle's saying you're not given like
i may have described it you're giving a
clock in the sense that like your
character has something they have to do
right quickly but there's nothing like
like you've got 10 hours to get this
done before the end and we're going to
start the clock now it it's it's more
that like
it just doesn't make sense narratively
for you to be around
when there's something very pressing
that's going on that you need to take
care of
uh yeah so it's very much like mass
effect and then it's like yeah i'm gonna
do these things because they're
really good well written they're really
interesting and like
some of those side quests make really
good use of the setting
but it just it
like there's this feeling in the back of
your head that's like i shouldn't be
doing this
i like i shouldn't be doing this and i i
think it's fair to say too
that like kind of like what we said up
front that
once you finish the game it takes you
back to a save and then you can kind of
clear out those quests so i think a lot
of that stuff is there
for folks who want more out of the game
and want to keep exploring want to keep
seeing that
which which is great like i'm not one
to be mad at more content and whatnot
but like it does feel at odds with what
you're trying to do
i mean part of me feels and questions
that maybe
it's just something that they put all of
this content in
to cater for so many different play
styles and so many different players
but the cohesion like the final the
final thing just doesn't come together
as well as maybe they'd hoped
i i think like emblematic of that is
like yeah it does feel
at points like you could approach things
in a
variety of ways but there are certain
instances of like like i personally
wanted to be
a hacker net runner type i wanted to
hack my way through combat situations
and stealth my way through them i wasn't
really
interested in like typical combat
right and there's points where the game
forces you into typical combat scenarios
and i was like
and i was like i feel unprepared i feel
like
and i was able to use the quick
quick hacking is what it's called i was
able to use that to kind to to navigate
my way through those fights
to some extent but like that's kind of
what i mean by their stuff i feel like i
didn't fully explore like weapons i feel
like i didn't
mess with my weapons at all there's a
bunch of weapon attachments i didn't
bother with i got mantis blades like way
later and i used them like once
um yeah it's
it's partially i think a pacing issue
part of that is the amount of time we
had to play the game and how many hours
we were playing every day but like
also just the way that the game is
structured it's like i have i felt like
i had so much more to do
but i needed to go do that final quest
and i was like i have barely touched
like i looked at my my inventory and i
was like i don't even know what half of
these things
are because i've just barely touched it
so you mentioned you brought up combat
there so
how is first person combat
in cyberpunk especially given you know
cd projekt's track record of being a
traditionally third person developer
like
does does combat feel good like
so i i think it depends like early on i
was having a bit of trouble with combat
because
i was so focused on shooting and i feel
like shooting people was one of the only
options i really had
and at least on pc we haven't played on
consoles so it could be very different
on console but on pc
it feels about as good as i expected uh
it's
it's better than like a fallout other
other first person rpgs
in that sense like aiming does feel
smoother than that
the the the lock on or the soft lock
feels better than that
um that being said like if you're
expecting call of duty
levels it it it's nowhere near that but
once you start to get more abilities and
once you
try out different things like for
example i was doing a lot of hacking as
was cali
i think it starts to shine quite a bit
more because
like one example that i found really fun
is when i try to stealth i have an
ability that basically blinds enemies
so right when i see the little eye that
they're about to see me i just
shock their eyes and like pretty much
just blow out their eye sockets and they
can't seem anymore and i can just sneak
around them grab them and knock them out
and like that stuff i found super
satisfying like i had a lot of fun with
the hacking
but it took a while to get to that point
where i felt comfortable just relying on
hacking because
even though i was quote unquote a
netrunner or hacker
early on i didn't really feel like i
have the tools
i had the tools to do that i'm currently
replaying it now
to see if maybe i can lean more into
that hacking ability early on
but based on that first playthrough i
felt like i had to use my guns way more
than i would have
liked to otherwise yeah i felt the same
way especially because money is kind of
hard to
to come by early on and you need money
to
properly upgrade your hacking equipment
like you need a better processor
with more ram in your brain in order to
pull off that like the blinding
enemies or there's a variety of stuff i
got a really cool one
very late in the game that was like i
was like this is so cool i have to equip
this right now
um but there's like a point early on
where you have to have a certain amount
of money to do
to progress and then there's another
money gated
thing so it was hard to get to the point
like jake said where you feel like an
effective hacker
um and yeah i mean i play a lot of first
person shooters and i came
right off the call of duty review just
playing call of duty into this review
and so
it's it's not fair to compare it to call
of duty like jake said that's just not a
fair expectation but
i did find it clunky i fill a lot with
sensitivity
um and i i couldn't really find a
sensitivity that i found
to to feel the way i wanted it to feel
right um which is why i was frustrated
by the points in the game where you have
to you kind of have to take out a gun
where because i was like
i really wish i could just do this the
way that
um i've been building my character to do
the whole game
right so not unlike the game itself
uh this conversation a lot to cover
um originally we're only supposed to do
15 minutes but honestly like just
chatting to you two about the game
i don't care let's keep going but the
big thing that i wanted to address with
you guys
is bugs because obviously we saw the
reports and
you had the download yourselves like you
got the game and then a few days later
there was a 40-something gigabyte patch
to address the game has been pushed
multiple times there's also gonna be a
day one patch
cali you even mentioned up front like
you can't currently finish the final
boss fight because
the game is freezing
how is it running
you want to start cali yes i want to
preface this by saying
most of the time when i'm reviewing a
game especially because most of the time
i review a game pre-release
i'm very forgiving of technical issues
because
i think technical issues can be patched
out and i like to focus on the
fundamental issues with the game if
there
are any when i'm critiquing a game but
oh my god there are so many bugs
i i think i didn't go through a single
sequence without hitting a bug like
i there are a lot of visual bugs like ui
stuff that would stay on the screen
um and the tricky thing is in and out
yes
the characters moving erratically um
stuff floating in the air
when it shouldn't be um so like
a lot of those that aren't game breaking
but just kind of like
intrusive and then and then you know i
had hard crashes i have the freezing
issue right now where i i'm gonna try
again because i want to see this ending
but
i if it freezes one more time i'm just
i'm going to lose it i was so frustrated
earlier
yeah there were just times where i was
like i can't tell if i'm i'm stuck
because i'm dumb or like
if something's not popping and a lot of
times it was because like whatever
was supposed to pop wasn't pop so
that's really frustrating obviously it's
a massive game it just feels like the
scale of this game
is is too big there's just too much um
i feel that way about the fundamental
narrative aspect of it and i feel that
way about
the level of
execution on on the the moment to moment
yeah i mean i've i'm playing on a very
expensive pc rig
and i have had and i've had an absurd
amount of bugs
i haven't had any crashes i haven't had
any game breaking stuff
there's been a few times where i've had
to roll back saves because of
a character maybe just didn't go to
where they're supposed to go in order to
progress the quest line
but usually just reloading to say fix
that but to cali's point
the amount of visual glitches i've seen
are like
through the roof uh like todd howard
probably
like i don't want to invoke his name
but like it feels very much like a
bethesda game when
i look at all of these bugs uh because
it it really does start to take you out
of the experience and
obviously like callie said this is a
massive game
there is a lot of you know qa you have
to do to make sure
that this game runs well and
like i said it it it runs pretty well
i haven't had any game breaking issues i
haven't had any crashes but the amount
of
people that pop into frame when they're
not supposed to the amount of like
weird lighting changes that happen while
i'm driving around that clearly aren't
supposed to happen
uh the amount of characters that i've
seen
just rocking the good old t-pose or
standing in the air or something like
that
is is ridiculous i've had hud elements
stuck to my screen that aren't supposed
to be there
um not to mention in cut scenes when
characters
talk when they're not supposed to like i
had a whole cuts
not cut scene but like a whole sequence
like 10 15 minutes where a character
kept saying like a
throwaway line that they would say like
if you bumped into them
in between and over the actual dialogue
and i was like
missing what i was supposed to be
hearing yeah i had a character
say like so if you don't respond quick
enough in dialogue
the character will normally be like v
what's going on but i had a bug where
the character kept saying that while
they were giving me the lines
so it would be like v here's what i want
you to do v what's going on and it would
they'd just be overlapping and running
over each other constantly
uh so yeah the the bug situation is
is super hard to overlook uh i
like we played so we've gotten one patch
and i think there's supposed to be
another day one patch
hopefully they can work some of that
stuff out so by the time the people
watching at home are able to play they
won't run into as much issues
but like what's there is a lot and i
i i have a hard time believing that one
day one patch can really iron that stuff
out
interesting but it kind of remains to be
seen yeah it remains to be
seen um obviously we're shooting this uh
well ahead of time well
not that well ahead of time um
given how long that game is uh let's
wrap this up then cali your final review
is uh in written form over gamespot.com
we're gonna have the video review up as
soon
as we can but i mean it's a huge game
and obviously
a lot of complicated thoughts about it
it's been eight years since it's been
announced the hype levels
are out of this world did this game meet
your expectations
was it worth the wait you know i'm
sorry about that question because like
uh
yeah i mean quickly uh to the point of
like
us recording this we've recorded this
before i've started writing
so so i wasn't gonna be like oh and the
school race
yeah so this is more informal uh my kind
of like
like raw unedited thoughts because i
literally like i came to this
remote shoot we're doing just from
playing in the other room so like um
i will mention that you can you can read
my more organized thoughts
when i write them now but
uh yeah i no it didn't meet my
expectations
um there's so much in that story that
like i
i really thought it was gonna go
further it was gonna go places there was
gonna be something to say
um you know i i that's my biggest issue
with
with cyberpunk 2077 is i don't know if
it has anything to say
like it brings up all these things and
it's like i would have been happier like
if it
had a point that i totally disagreed
with but i can't find the point
um i think there's a lot of strengths
i think they're buried under like this
grimy facade of this
world that like i you know
it's kind of hard to be in sometimes
it's a depressing
world by design um i wish that the game
did more
with that setting and with the cyberpunk
genre
um in a lot of ways it feels stuck in
the 80s um
because that's when 2020 was made but
like
i think there's so much that could have
been elevated and
yeah i even hesitate to say it this way
because normally i don't talk about what
could have been but like
that's what you go into this game
thinking is like this is about the like
that's what
sci-fi and like future stories are about
right like what could be
what like what am i doing here there's
something to do
to like create could i change the world
you talk about changing the world all
the time and i just
didn't get that so
overall i would say i was i was
disappointed
i i personally my expectations were
pretty high
to be fair i've been waiting for this
game for a long time
i in some aspects yes i would say it
exceeded my expectation i think
one thing in particular was just i
thought the writing especially the side
quests
the the moment-to-moment dialogue i
thought was really good
especially after playing assassin's
creed origins assassin's creed odyssey
assassin's creed valhalla which clearly
rip off that
not rip off that witcher formula but but
lean heavily on that witcher formula
and the writing to me in those games
have always been subpar
however this feels
like like the the moment-to-moment
dialogue a lot of the quests seem
really interesting what the characters
have to say i'm fully invested
in so in that sense i
i'm i'm very impressed with the writing
the story is kind of another
topic i'm like i've beaten it once now
and i've seen multiple endings and i'm
not really
entirely sure what the point is either
kind of to cali's point i really enjoy
the combat
but i i don't know i guess i was
expecting like
a little more freedom
i guess in in the approach in the way
the story was told it was really hard to
embrace that freedom even though it was
kind of there but like i was saying
earlier there was that feeling
throughout the entire game where it was
like okay
i'm not really doing what i want to do
i'm doing v's quest which
is great and you know that's one of the
reasons why i love the witcher 3 so much
is because you
are following geralt's quest and
geralt's quest is very compelling
but i kind of went into cyberpunk
expecting it would be more about my
story
uh kind of like kind of like in you know
a traditional role-playing
game and this felt a bit more that i was
following v
story which would have been fine but i
don't know
if v story was as compelling as
the witcher 3 so following it i found a
little bit tougher
interesting well um we've been going for
a long time
so i'm going to call it the thank you
both so much
uh for hopping on it's it's late already
um
cali you've got to go and write that
review um
which i don't envy you trying to distill
all of those thoughts into one piece but
godspeed
and you can go read that over on
gamespot.com
uh remember to like this video and
subscribe for our video review
and a lot more coverage of cyberpunk
we've got a lot of things in the uh
in the pipeline so you can watch them
here
thanks again for joining us we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you